>> RICK SANTORUM SORBENT AS A
SENATOR FROM THE STATE OF
PENNSYLVANIA FOR MORE THAN A
DECADE HE BECAME A POLITICAL
COMMENTATOR IN HAVING REALLY
SPOKE TO HIM FOR A NEW EPISODE
OF TUCKER CARLSON TODAY THE
CONVERSATION WASN'T JUST ABOUT
POLITICS, RICK SANTORUM SHARED
DEEPLY PERSONAL STORY ABOUT THE
MOST CHALLENGING MOMENT IN HIS
LIFE.
JUST PART OF THE CONVERSATION.
♪
>> THEY FIND OUT THAT THEIR
CHILD IS DISABLED IN THEY DON'T
WANT THEIR CHILD ANYMORE.
AND IT WAS STUNNING TO ME THAT
SHE WOULD MAKE THAT A MISSION,
THAT YOU WOULD CALL THE RANKS O
THE DISABLED AND SO THAT WAS A
CENTRAL PART OF MY DATE MY END
GOT UP AND I SAID, MANY STORIES
BUT ONE WAS I SAID MY WIFE WAS
19 AND PREGNANT, I HAVE A
SONOGRAM SCHEDULED THE NEXT WEE
AT 20 WEEKS, AND I DON'T KNOW
WHETHER MY CHILD IS GOING TO BE
HEALTHY OR NOT, BUT IF MY CHILD
IS SOMEHOW NOT HEALTHY, I'M NOT
GOING TO KILL IT, WHY WOULD I
KILL MY CHILD JUST BECAUSE MY
CHILD HAS A MEDICAL PROBLEM?
YOU LOVE THE GIFT THAT GOD GIVE
IT FOR HOWEVER LONG GOD GIVES I
TO GO.
WE DON'T KNOW HOW LONG WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE OUR CHILDREN OR
HOW LONG WE'RE GOING TO BE ALIVE
.
SO I SAY THAT, AND A WEEK LATER
WE HAVE THE SONOGRAM IN WE ARE
SITTING THERE GOING OVER THIS
ONE SPOT ON THE SONOGRAM IN HE
SAYS I HAVE TO GET THE DOCTOR.
THE DOCTOR COMES IN AND SAYS HE
LOOKS AT ME AND SAYS AS COLD AS
I CAN EVER REMEMBER HE SAID YOU
SON HAS A FATAL DEFECT AND HE'S
GOING TO DIE.
SO THIS WAS DURING MY TIME WITH
WHERE I'M SORT OF GROWING IN MY
FAITH IN HAVING THIS EXPERIENCE
AND I TALK ABOUT FINDING THE
LORD, TAKING ON THIS GREAT WHAT
I THOUGHT WAS AN IMPORTANT MORA
CAUSE FOR THE COUNTRY IN THEN
BOOM, YOU KNOW, I REMEMBER
HAVING THIS CONVERSATION WITH
GOD AND SAYING HERE I AM TRYING
TO FOLLOW YOUR PATH, AND YOU
TAKE MY SON?
SO IT WAS DEVASTATING.
WE DID EVERYTHING WE COULD TO
TRY TO SAVE HIS LIFE WE HAD HIM
AT THE CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL IN
PHILADELPHIA HAD INTRAUTERINE
SURGERY TO TRY TO FIX THE
PROBLEM.
OUR LITTLE BOY LIVED FOR TWO
HOURS.
I THOUGHT YOU KNOW, WHAT ARE YO
DOING.
WHY ARE YOU DOING THIS?
GOD WHY, WHY, WHY, THE GREATEST
QUESTION EVERYBODY WHO GOES
THROUGH TRAGEDY, WHY DID THIS
HAPPEN TO ME?
AND WHAT HAPPENED, IT WASN'T ME
IT WAS MY WIFE WHO MADE IT ALL
COME TOGETHER.
EVERY TIME WE KEEP DIARY TO
SHARE IT WITH A KID SO THIS IS
WHAT IT WAS LIKE AND SO SHE
COULD SHARE THIS NOTES NOTE
STRAIGHT SHE WAS NEED DON'T
NEONATAL INTENSIVE CARE NURSE,
SO PREGNANCIES WERE JOYFUL TIME
AND SHE WOULD KEEP NOTES VERY
SHE WAS KEEPING NOTES ABOUT OUR
SON SO SHE KEPT WRITING THESE
LETTERS TO HIM.
HOPING SOMEDAY HE WOULD READ
THEM.
SO SHE WROTE THESE LETTERS IN A
THE END, SHE KEPT WRITING
BECAUSE IT WAS HER WAY TO GET
THE STUFF OUT SO SHE WROTE THIS
AND HER MOTHER READ THEM WHO
WOULD LAST A CHILD 50 YEARS AGO
AND FROM ACIDS DEATH IN IT JUST
BROKE HER UP AND SHE SAID WE
HAVE TO PUBLISH THIS.
WE HAVE TO PUBLISH THESE LETTERS
.
ANYWAY, WE FOUND A CATHOLIC
PUBLISHER TO PUBLISH IT, IT SOL
OUT IN IT STILL AROUND IT'S
CALLED LETTERS TO GABRIEL.
>> WHAT AN UNBELIEVABLE STORY I
YOU CAN WATCH TUCKER'S FULL
INTERVIEW WITH RICK SANTORUM